I have to ask you to pray the most
important question now did you it's true
or not true that you decided to do this
rogue one prequel series because they're
gonna put Jabba the Hutt in it so you
can I haven't III guess my life will
change the day I get to find out what's
the texture of a skin
I love how one thing you say one day in
the middle of like a hundred and fifty
interviews suddenly haunts you for the
rest of your life right it's incredible
it's incredible what has happened with
that the amount of I love it I love it
but I still wanna touch ya by the hood
why wouldn't you yeah but being actually
serious I loved your character in that
film and think it's right for
exploration when did you find out that
the show that you were going to do this
very recently that's why I know very
little very recently and I am thrilled
and happy it's it's a dream come true to
go back to that universe you know yes I
grew up watching those films and and and
now I'm sharing that with my kids so I'm
very happy my last question about that
do you have any idea when because
they're filming Mandalorian now and I
can't wait for that but do you know when
you might be filming the show that I
don't know no no but it's definitely
happening though I know as much as you
know I promise it's like that thing that
was sent to the press got sent to me a
day before of I get a listen I'm lookin
grats on this I'm looking forward to
that and I hope to see you directing
again soon oh me too me too
thank you very thank you so much
you